let's go back to the phones a lot of
people holding on we'll try our caller
from the eight one three area code
caller from eight one three who's this
what's on your mind today
hopefully it's me hi this is Andrew just
had a quick not really a question more
just this great well no I guess it is a
question have you come across Trump
supporters trying to justify the tax or
not tax evasion but the non-disclosure
of trumps tax forms by saying something
essentially along the lines of oh he
can't reveal his tax information because
if he does then people will see the
great tricks and secrets to becoming
vastly wealthy and successful no I've
not I've not come across that one so so
if I understand it what you're saying is
the idea that Trump has become
successful because of the way that he
files his taxes and if he published his
tax returns everybody would be able to
do that it's a stupid argument because
in order to have enough money to do
creative things with your taxes you
already need to have the money so it's
like a chicken egg thing you know and
and that's exactly the way I thought I
thought of it unfortunately the person
who was telling me was a co-worker that
I'm I had to work fairly closely with
and probably still do in the future so
I'm sorry I can't how I can't tell
people OFF when they make claims like
that it's just one of those amazing like
did you really just say that I just
wondering if I've never heard that one
before no but you know what it's an
example of Andrew there's this thing
called special pleading right and a
really good example is in in Carl
Sagan's book science as a demon haunted
world science as a candle in the dark
where he says listen someone comes to
you and they say and I think it's from
that book is that there's a there's a
dragon in my garage and you say great
let's go look at the dragon and they say
well it's an invisible dragon so even if
we went you we wouldn't be able to see
it it's like okay well what we'll do is
we'll spread flour and then use lasers
and the dragon will interrupt the laser
so we'll be able to
see the outline of the Dragon even if
the dragon is invisible well they know
the dragon is made of something that is
impervious to laser so then you say okay
how about this let's spread powdered
sugar on the floor of your garage and as
the dragon walks around even if it's
invisible and impervious to laser it'll
disturb the powdered sugar on the floor
of the garage and they say no because
it's weightless as well so it's not
going it's what's called a special every
time there's going to be some reason why
it's it's untestable so even if with
your coworker you explain why that's
idiocy they would just come up with some
other reason you know probably probably
they're yeah they seem like one of this
I don't want to speak for them because
they're not here but I'd imagine that's
very possible that's very much a
possibility yes you can do but all right
thank you very much appreciate a call
great to hear from you